Traductor: Yoshinori Casas
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
En 1800, el explorador
Alexander von Humboldt
vio varias anguilas eléctricas
saliendo del agua
para defenderse de unos caballos.
La mayoría de las personas creyeron
que Humboldt inventó la historia.
Pero los peces eléctricos
son más usuales de lo que creemos;
y sí, las anguilas eléctricas
son un tipo de pez.
Debajo del agua, donde la luz es escaza,
las señales eléctricas
son una forma de comunicación,
navegación,
y en algunos casos extraños
aturdimiento de la presa.
Cerca de 350 especies de peces
tienen estructuras especializadas
en generar o detectar señales eléctricas.
Estos peces están divididos en dos grupos,
dependiendo de cuánta
electricidad producen.
Los científicos llaman al primer grupo
los peces de electricidad débil.
Las estructuras cerca de la cola
llamadas órganos eléctricos
producen hasta dos tercios
del potencial de una batería AA.
¿Cómo funcionan?
El cerebro envía una señal a través
del sistema nervioso al órgano eléctrico,
que está lleno de grupos de cientos
o miles de discos celulares
llamados electrocitos.
Normalmente, los electrocitos
liberan iones de sodio y potasio
para mantener una carga positiva externa
y una carga negativa interna.
Pero cuando la señal nerviosa
llega al electrocito,
permite el flujo de iones.
Los iones positivos fluyen al interior.
Ahora, un lado del electrocito
tiene carga negativa externa
y carga positiva interna.
Pero el lado opuesto
tiene la carga opuesta.
Estas cargas alternas
pueden conducir una corriente,
convirtiendo al electrocito
en una batería biológica.
La clave del poder de los peces
son las señales coordinadas del nervio
para llegar a cada célula al mismo tiempo.
Esto genera que los grupos de electrocitos
actúen como miles de baterías en serie.
Las pequeñas cargas de cada uno
se acumulan en un campo eléctrico
que puede viajar varios metros.
Las células llamadas electroreceptores
ubicadas al fondo de la piel
permiten al pez sentir este campo
y los cambios generados
por el entorno u otro pez.
Por ejemplo, el pez de nariz elefante,
tiene un mentón alargo llamado
el órgano de Schnauzen
que está lleno de electroreceptores.
Este le permite recibir
señales de otro pez,
medir distancias,
detectar forma y tamaño
de objetos cercanos,
e incluso determinar si un insecto
enterrado está vivo o muerto.
Pero el pez nariz elefante
y otros peces de electricidad débil
no producen suficiente electricidad
para atacar a su presa.
Esa capacidad la tienen
los peces de electricidad fuerte,
de los cuales solo hay
unas cuantas especies.
El pez eléctrico más poderoso
es el pez cuchillo eléctrico,
comúnmente llamado anguila eléctrica.
Tres órganos eléctricos cubren
casi todo su cuerpo de 2 metros.
Como el pez de electricidad débil,
la anguila eléctrica usa sus señales
para navegación y comunicación,
pero guarda la descarga eléctrica
más fuerte para cazar
usando un ataque en dos fases
para ubicar e incapacitar a su presa.
Primero, emite dos o tres pulsos fuertes,
de hasta 600 voltios.
Los cuales estimulan los músculos
de la presa para generarle espasmos
y crear ondas que revelan
dónde está oculta.
Luego, una descarga rápida de alto voltaje
causa contracciones musculares
mucho más intensas.
La anguila eléctrica también se puede
enrollar para que los campos eléctricos
generados al final de cada
órgano eléctrico se sobrepongan.
La tormenta eléctrica eventualmente
cansa e inmoviliza a la presa,
y la anguila eléctrica puede
comer su alimento vivo.
Los otros dos peces de electricidad fuerte
son el pez gato eléctrico,
el cual puede generar 350 voltios
con un órgano eléctrico que ocupa
la mayor parte del torso,
y la raya eléctrica, con órganos
eléctricos en ambos lados de la cabeza
los cuales producen hasta 220 voltios.
Aún existe un misterio a cerca
de los peces eléctricos:
¿por qué no se electrocutan ellos mismos?
Puede ser que el tamaño
de los peces eléctricos fuertes
les permita resistir su propia descarga,
o que la corriente atraviese
muy rápido su cuerpo.
Algunos científicos creen que
algunas proteínas especiales
pueden estar cubriendo
los órganos eléctricos.
pero la verdad, es que aún existe
un misterio científico sin resolver.